yeah welcome to this video playing 45
need to start to stick to my trusty
openings rating has suffered so much I
need to play it safe of it yeah I don't
need to but what I want to falling below
2200 really would be a yeah bit weird
okay we have a somewhat uncommon for
more firm of the Italian game with a
quick Queen e2 but it's not a big issue
this Queen placement that same the
typical rather solid structure you often
get in the JUCO piano pianissimo I think
it is you court I'm not sure no
pianissimo was in with you tonight c3 I
guess this is just JUCO piano
okay whatever the name is it's a it's
not very exciting
I came intending to play d4 F let's
let's check and play d5 myself 95 it's
not a big problem I think
95 I can probably only just advances I
didn't expect that maybe even night to
h5 now why not actually we should be
three it has an immediate justification
and if you place that this may be f6 f6
why not that's ok 95 ok this is this is
fine someone probably missed my group
here on a 7 did you need to get it back
into play group 2 ei that's really the
piece belongs on he ate
oh so this is surprising but he allows
this with the temple gain you know the
question is oh yeah I'm surprised with
every move I thought I've thought Queen
d2 okay I need to open your phone anyway
I thought that Queen d2 would put more
pressure on the deep one but he's got
some other intentions it seems so this
is at the moment I'm covered but that's
of course not a great square I don't
want to be opposite the roof so let's
get the Queen away maybe queen h5 also
also a possibility and of course 92 what
does I can just take and see five at
least see five you can take and take d5
averted servants in exchange okay yeah I
think he must take on more therefore
really if he drops back and I get to
play c4 I just really busted I admit
that I really didn't see that it happens
hanging there I've got 92 actually and
this is this is good but I didn't I
didn't see that it was like he gave 92 I
think now queen f2 is the real problem
Mucca Mucca d5 then okay my dad's take a
chemist and wrap him smoke f4o before
yeah
Knight to Queen to b6
hmm Queen to b6 up maybe it's not going
that I was always thinking about taking
on h3 but you can take d5 with the check
this is the problem
the check is the problem but I can I can
just take here actually this is the
easiest and then d5 or queen Tiye for
Queen before even I ask upcoming g6 but
then I've got Bishop f7 ah this is good
let's get rid of the Queen's keep it
simple
Queen g6 verse bishop um f7 turning
rookie for now it's all cabot should win
the night
okay I continues it's just a rook really
like yeah funny I really didn't see that
that he can take it it's probably good
anyway but absolutely I was oblivious to
this to this possibility
oh man I think the computer actually
gives c6 as much better this is simple
and good but I didn't see that he can
take it I've just thought ok needs to
retreat a place before he sacrifices c6
in fact is strong I just make sure that
d5 is protected and I just have a strong
attack on the King without any big
counter play between h5 v 5 is also very
weak pawn he played some some weird some
weird stuff around here this is a
surprise me already and Queen d2 yeah
this already looks that looks very nice
it just this is a weakness and I have
this ideas on g2 on h3 and what doesn't
have any any real and you will plan to
whatever is that yeah Queen takes is a
mistake this this is some the problem
this is okay I thought that you would
probably need to excel to give the
exchange but of it's also clear that
there's compensation cannot take from
link yes this looks oh look so stupid
you know and this yeah it's um it's very
likely to be enough compensation okay
yeah thanks for watching